what about the second the second one
it's called starshot you know starshot
means like
big dreams and it's an initiative by the
breakthrough foundation
and starshot is the concept to send
thousands of little tiny spacecraft
which they now call star chip so instead
of starship it's star chip
and there's a little chip and the star
chip
so like sending like thousands of little
turtles being born they're not all going
to make it
mm-hmm because they used to send lots of
them and each of these star chips
once they're launched into i guess
low-earth orbit they will
deploy a solar sail that's a few meters
in diameter
and they'd use it on earth we would have
a bank
of this one is still a bit on the other
side of the line but
we'd have a bank of telescopes with
lasers
there'd be like a gigawatt power and
these lasers would momentarily
shine upwards and accelerate they'd hit
these sails they'd be like a power
source for the sale
and would accelerate the sails to travel
at about a 20th the speed of light
is that is that as crazy as it sounds
well
like like any good well like any good
engineering project it has to be broken
down into the crazy parts
and the breakthrough initiative like to
their huge credit is
sponsoring you know getting over these
actually they've listed initially they
listed 19 challenges yes it's broken
down to concrete things
like one of them is well you have to buy
the land and make sure the airspace is
okay
with you setting up that much power
overhead
another one is you have to have material
on the sail where the lasers won't just
uh
vaporize it and well so there's a lot of
a lot of issues but anyway these sails
would be accelerated to 20th speed of
light
and their journey to the nearest star
would now wouldn't would no longer be
tens of thousands of years but could be
20 years okay 20. so it's not
not as bad as tens of thousands yeah and
this um these thousands or whatever
however many make it they'll go by the
nearest star system and snap a few snap
some images
and radio the information back to earth
because they're traveling so fast they
can't slow down but they'll zoom by take
some photos
send it back high res yeah but see just
what i want you to pause on for a second
is that
just by making that a real concept and
the money given won't make it happen but
we'll
but what it's done is it's planted the
seed and it's shifted that line from
what is crazy to what is a real project
it's shifted it just ever so slightly
enough i think to plant the seed that we
have to find a way to somehow find a way
to get there
that is again to stay on that that is so
powerful take a big crazy idea
and break it down into smaller crazy
ideas order it in a list
and knock it out one at a time
i i don't know i've never heard anything
more inspiring from an engineering
perspective
because that's how you solve the
impossible things
you